you asked me what I do here this is what
I do I find you players and I feel it
this time yeah okay it's risky when you
were selling sneakers out of the back of
your Plymouth that was risky don't
change that now for a rookie yes who's
never set foot on an NBA court that's
the literal definition of rookie yeah
I'll have to go ahead and say it as much
as like the cast I've already been
bragging about the performance as an
incomparable Miss Viola Davis and
obviously bringing her partner along
that's an added bonus but for me I just
have to say the music like I don't feel
like enough people are talking about it
because listen Amazon I think came for
you with that Amazon music like let's be
real you guys said you know the movie
Incredible and they don't even do like
soundtracks really anymore like they
used to where you you know you just now
it's like a Spotify playlist or a
playlist on Amazon or actually well I'm
not I'm whatever company but you know
that's uh I love you know we worked
worked hard on it actually allocated a
lot of the spend on the movie because I
thought like the music really needs to
drive the story and be propulsive and
keep reminding you of the time and so
you know and I really wanted to choose
across all the genres that I remember
because it was before really like
hip-hop and rap music had become pop
music it was a sub genre you know and it
was like I can remember getting my
Houdini tape you know for Christmas and
like kids being like you know
you know what's that I mean you know
there was like heavy metals over here
and pop was that kind of like uh middle
I mean there was your Prince Michael
Jackson Cyndi Lauper Boy George but it
really was a gamut and besides the fact
it was like that synth sound that was
pretty dominant there was actually a lot
of really interesting music that was
being made and at the time I remember
everyone was like
oh the this isn't like the good old days
or whatever you know that was all the
music that I really grew up on in my
neighborhood and which is why I was kind
of in tune with the what was like the
changing evolution of the
um athletic wear Styles going from
Adidas and Shell Toes and tractors the
Pumas who's into into Nike and how that
just like almost overnight was really
different and part of that was because I
was trying at one time to be a break
dancer I heard about that yes I was okay
I need another 10 minutes to do that but
Chris I want to make sure I talk about
this I know this was a collaboration
both from what Alex put on the page and
then obviously between Ben's Direction
and what you brought just from shaping
this character or this person Howard but
what was the central themes of who
Howard was that you wanted to make sure
stayed through all of that because I
think that's more important obviously I
know can just tell how much you put into
this role but I'm curious what were the
core tenants so you didn't get lost that
he was a positive guy and I was glad
they was able to fit in there because
everybody was telling you know uh Matt's
character no don't go don't do this
though and then how was like hey what
the hell you know uh you do it you know
you you know you made me believe so I
that was like when I found that I was
like oh this is gonna work and um that
it yeah and everybody told me like
Charles Barkley all his teachers and
coaches said how would this either he
was just what you call it uh naive or he
just believed in and hoped in the the
you know positive positivity so yeah I
wanted that to come he brought that like
optimism you know that was really the
heart of the movie that spirit that you
can make things happen you know you can
make difficult things happen Howard if
you talk to him you know it turns out
face enormous challenges in his life and
and accomplished enormous amount so it's
like really really present in Christmas
performance who that is and that energy
kind of comes through in the movie yeah
people don't know what the hell a Nike
is what's a Converse NBA All-Star shoes
there's nothing cool about Nike
you would have to have a pretty
compelling pitch I can tell them the one
thing the other companies can't compete
with
our basketball Division is terrible I do
not love it Matt I'm gonna go ahead and
start with you because one of the things
I found out getting prepared for this
was the idea that you and Ben sort of
lamented the lack of sort of uh
collaborations throughout the years and
it kind of poses the question well which
one would you want to intercert yourself
in would you want to be an Armageddon
would you want him to be in Jason Bourne
or which random franchise would both of
you just like to sort of join if you had
a choice like looking back in the lens
of History well I think it's less about
like looking back at what was made and
looking back at what we might have made
had we written stuff and just made I
think you know
it took us so long to write Goodwill
Hunting
um because we didn't really know what we
were doing that I think that put us off
writing together because I think we both
assumed it would be that time and labor
intensive the second time around and so
when we wrote the last duel and it
happened really quickly and we realized
oh we've just been both making movies
for like 30 years like we really know
what what the structure is like and and
uh like we should be doing this a lot
more often
also I will say
realized something today when I was
leaving the press conference I did both
of your press conferences for that so
now I feel like I'm a third person like
inserting myself a little bit like Cole
Hauser or something
you're you're welcome you can come to
our company so I'ma hold you to that
anyway Marlin
sir I definitely want to talk to you
about about your care look well the man
that you're portraying George this
incredible man who lived this incredible
life but I also want to talk about this
Wild Weekend that you had to prepare for
this role I just have to say does it
make it easier does it make it harder
when you get to call it a Friday and
have to walk on to set on a Monday it
absolutely makes it harder because you
don't have no time you gotta you know
you gotta you it's a crash course so you
got to get your YouTube on you got to
read fast uh you have to listen it's a
lot of listening because you're trying
to get the rhythm of how he speaks and a
little bit of the action I don't like
doing not an impression but just you
want the isms to me I call them the isms
um uh and it's just learning getting the
the soul of the character and then once
you have that then you start to play and
you melt them with you and you melt them
with what your skill set is and then you
start thinking oh you know be funny is
this and talking to my friend and what
kind of com conversation that would be
and then then it's once you get to set
just throwing everything out the window
and just sitting with a a great actor
and enjoying your time on on set so yeah
I don't want to spoil
spoilers for folks that don't know who
he is I can't wait for them to discover
it through the course of the narrative
it's so great the way the script sort of
like tells his story both in the story
but then also afterwards but Matt for
you I think it's like but about this
bigger theme like George took a risk
Sonny took a risk Phil took a risk and I
think it's sort of when you think about
it for yourself it's a risk what you
guys are doing both with the Equity Fund
with choosing to produce again it's
always a risk to make a movie but what's
been the best bet of your career like
which one are you the happiest with like
looking back on it or or one that you
sort of like say to yourself hot God I'm
so glad I did this because the whole
thing would have been different and
Marlon I'll come to you with the same
question in a minute I mean it would
have to be partnering with my best
friend you know all those years ago that
that changed everything I think I'm I
think if I have any skill it's it's
picking Partners I'm I I've been good at
that in this life I've been you know
from Ben to my wife to you know my my
the co-founder of water dot org Gary
White like I it's just been a um I've
really benefited from from
being associated with brilliant people
oh that's sweet um and Marlon I'll ask
you the same thing you again always
comedians going up on a stage is a risk
every night oh absolutely
um I thought he was asking about him I
was going to say Jason Bourne man
I picked that one no um
you know everything every movie we
ever done has been a risk everything
yeah
um just getting one done is like a gut
instinct and you spend all this time
writing it and you know producing it and
putting it together when you do that
from Soup To Nuts it's a year of your
life and there's been a lot of years of
my life that I've I've given and I agree
with Matt you know where it's like doing
what you love with who you love is like
the best thing in the world and I would
say that uh embarking on the journey
with my brothers whether it be in Scary
Movie Don't Be a Menace White Chicks
little man it doesn't matter which movie
we did together we always had a great
time on the set and we accomplished two
things at one time
my name is Sonny Vaccaro I'm with Nike
do typically make it a habit of showing
up at people's front doors unannounced I
don't like to take no for an answer oh
man here we go I have to start with you
Miss Viola Davis because I think on top
of everything else what I really loved
is when you speak about Dolores and what
you really wanted to honor her in this
movie and how you wanted to make sure
you were faithful to her as I think you
said zen-like presents please talk to me
about that and and what specific aspects
of her personalities you wanted to make
sure shown through all of these very
tense negotiations
um the fact that she's an observer
the fact that
she takes everything in and stores it
the fact that she's Brave
and she understands boundaries it's like
she told Sunny you know it's not time
for you to see my son yet I don't think
that she has any problems taking the
reins
and especially when it comes to family
and I admire the fact that when she sat
with Sonny what she wanted to know was
she wanted to know about him as a man as
a person that for her was her calling
card not his stats but him so for me all
of those things added up to a person
you know when you play a character you
can't I can't look at the Nike deal and
go Dolores brokered the deal she's the
one but you can't play that you know it
hasn't happened in the film yet but what
you do have to honor is the character
traits that allowed that to happen and
so for me it was keeping steady though
those steady you know people who can
negotiate they know their worth their
their like they're they're like lions
but internalized Lions I wanted to
capture that and that's very very
difficult because I'm the person who's
like I told well like I said bombastic
sometimes I get really anxious
I don't see her as being that woman
yeah and I would say that is just
surprising for me to hear but again so
much more of a testament to what we get
to see on screen I can't wait for folks
to see this movie Mr Julius sir I do
have to say it was such a pleasant
Revelation to hear as you were speaking
earlier the fact that the dynamic that
you so brilliantly played on screen is
similar to Dynamic that you guys have at
home so I guess I would have to say for
such uh this is probably one of the
easiest and hardest days to come to work
like it's probably like the best of
everything in the sense that you get to
have your easy relationship but also
difficult because in that easiness you
don't want to forget who you're honoring
and the man
exactly well I mean listen Viola and our
relationship is just yesterday yin and
yang I mean we just we we work it out
we just work it out so coming to work to
do this role and having the opportunity
to you know kind of be husband and wife
as we are in real life and then looking
at the Jordans and who they were and
respect affecting that and honoring that
because as always when you come into a
set as an actor I never think about what
Biola is going to do I know what she's
going to do but I know what I have to do
so you keep that balance of you know the
Artistry and then the relationship but
then you mail that together then you you
get what you got on screen and that's
kind of our everyday that's our every
day and when we looked at the Jordans we
saw that as kind of who they were also
so it was easy it was fun it was a lot
of fun playing together we enjoy it
what's the plan we build a shoe line
around just him I need the greatest
basketball shoe that's ever been made
who's the player
Michael Jordan I will start with you
Jason sir because I believe your
character the monologue that he does is
like I said I don't want to like put too
much in it but it is a very great
encapsulation of what's happening and
some of the risks that everyone kind of
has to take with it but more importantly
he's kind of the voice of reason
throughout all of this Insanity what was
it like sort of being like I think the
the one person maybe in the room that's
like at least asking the question of
like are we sure
yeah there's uh there's consequences to
what uh Matt Damon's character is uh is
pursuing obviously in the in the in the
business world the the consequences uh
the pluses and the mices are pretty
obvious but then there's also this human
side of it that there's real people
working at this company and what he's
proposing is it could be very disruptive
so I think it was just really smart on
the screenwriters part to make that part
as uh tangible for the audience as as
the basketball side of it because you
know there might not be a bunch of
basketball fans uh sitting in the
audience and so
um that was uh it was nice to nice to
sort of ground the movie in in that one
spot but for the most part it's just a
really fun ride but um been directed it
in such a way where he could go to that
if he wanted to or needed to and he does
there Chris I have to talk to you about
yours because it's a sports agent but
obviously this is the the work of all
agencies and and he's not really even
doing what you know you would consider
at that time to be the average thing
about a sports agent would even be doing
with a shoe deal uh I just have to ask
this randomly did you get more respect
from your agent did you use him as part
of the research process or was this all
about Falk and his sort of like I would
say very insistent negotiation practices
yeah my agents are much calmer or at
least they seem to be to me uh and maybe
a bit Kinder but but you know I it all
came from Falk really it all came from
what I knew about him or read about him
and and the script itself it was all it
was all right there I will say too you
talked a little bit about how you had to
set it up and that this was a new a new
situation
we share with you what was the most
surprising I would say benefit to that
sort of setup that you had with that one
yeah doing the phone calls at the same
time actually talking to somebody you
just get you know it's just live it's
just like doing a scene if we if Jason
and I were doing a scene right here it
just yeah I I could all his changes and
his highs and lows and even when he
found fog funny all that would just play
in real time rather than somebody trying
to create like Matt when we shot Matt he
did it like this so it was it was like
actually being in a scene in front of
him you know right through the phone
I love that um Jason I'm going to ask
both you and Chris this one so much of
this movie is again about making the bet
on your career that one that one yes
that you have to get because you know
everything else will be worth it I just
ask you to maybe reflect on your time on
camera or whatever what is sort of your
sunny moment what was that bet that you
were pleading with everyone about maybe
I don't know a little show that you did
recently I don't know what was your your
big sort of study moment
uh yeah that uh Ozark when I was uh
trying to talk them into letting me kind
of take the reins on that thing and and
um and be the guy and direct them all
and produce it and and yes act in it but
I I just I really wanted to try to
direct a 600 page movie and um and and
uh it was a long arduous not arduous but
it was it was a long meeting where I
really had to plead my case and um uh
and it worked out it was uh the stakes
were high
I love that Chris do you have a moment
like that for yourself I feel like every
day I have a moment
uh where I'm trying to you know
there's a lot of great actors and uh
they're they're you know and trying to
you know either win a part or convince
somebody that you could do something
different so every day is a a little bit
of a
um you know pushing the boulder up up
the mountain to try to get somewhere